What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And today we are here in Copenhagen
With the one and only -
Michael Maze.
How are you Michael?
I'm great!
I'm feeling good,
I'm at the Bröndy football stadium
It is my favorite club
So I feel perfect!
Great!
We are going to try out Butterfly's brand-new
Amicus Prime table tennis robot.
We are going to do some challenges between
us
Let's see how it goes!
Let's start with an accuracy battle.
The one who uses less shots and knocks down
all the cups, wins!
I'll go first.
That was pure luck.
Let's replace the cups with real table tennis
balls
to see who is more precise.
Sounds good to me - let's go!
I guess we can say that the last challenge
was pretty even.
Now - let's do the speed battle.
We will set the robot on max speed
And random distribution.
Next, we are going to go around the net.
Five forehand and five backhand!
Let's go!
Now, let's have a side spin battle.
Let's see how well we can handle the spin
of the robot
to knock down the pyramid.
Next, let's try the maximum underspin and
topspin of the robot.
I'm gonna beat you easily!
Alright, that's a wrap then for today!
Thank you very much Michael for having us
here!
Yeah, thank you.
It was my pleasure having you here
It was very very nice!
And a huge thanks to Butterfly
for making this video possible.
If you want to buy your own Butterfly robot
Remember to use the "Pongfinity" promotion
code
And get 72 table tennis balls for free.
Until next time!